so you guys have heard about Dr fosey
Khan talking about how to find bugs from
Deep learning programs and I will then
talk about how to figure out what goes
wrong figure out the root causes of the
this box
so this stays AI artificial intelligence
has been increasingly embedded into
modern software application that and the
systems and the key enabler behind this
is deep learning and you know deep
learning is quite different from
traditional software engineering in
traditional software development we
programmers manually write the program
logic in source code right but in deep
learning the models actually learn their
own logic from the training data and
also in traditional software development
everything is encoded in symbolic
representations right data structures
etc etc
but in deep learning things are encoded
into high dimensional arrays and there
is a lot of calculus and linear algebra
operations over this arrays to make the
inference
this brings a lot of challenge to debug
deep learning models
you know in the old world traditional
software if we want to debug error we
basically set a breakpoint and we can
step through each line of code to figure
out the root cause of this error
but in deep learning for neural net how
do we even set a breakpoint
even if sometimes we can actually peek
into the internal you know a specific
layer or neuron in the neural NAB but
what we can get from at the runtime the
runtime values we get from this neural
net are high dimensional arrays which
are hard to interpret right
all right let's actually look at one
example suppose you're a programmer and
you actually Trend this recurrent neural
network to classify ready comments to
positive or negative opinions
and you find out the model accuracy is
pretty low and you are wondering why
right so for example this comment
clearly shares a negative opinion but
the model misclassifies it as positive
so it's really hard to tell exactly what
happens inside the model right and why
this error occurs
and this is actually why some people you
know actually call Deep learning Alchemy
right people don't know exactly why
something works and why something
doesn't work okay it's like a giant
black box to us to programmers
our solution is to transform this
complex and familiar neural network back
to something we are familiar with right
like uh Finance day machine and in this
way we can bring back all the good stuff
we have in the traditional programming
world like people can step through each
state in the financial State machine and
inspect the state value
um in the in the financial State machine
So based on this idea we actually build
a debugging tool called The Deep seer in
the middle of this interface is a
visualization of the finite State
machine abstracted from an RN model and
it provides programmers a bird's eye
view of what's already going on in the
internal decision making process of the
model
and the model reads each word in input
text it will Transit between different
state until it reach to the end of the
text to make it the final decision
and if you click on state you can
actually see the frequent words and
phrases associated with this state so in
this way we convert those
uninterpretable High dimensional arrays
into a symbolic representation that are
interpretable to programmers
and you can also dig into individual
data points in the training data search
and filter and Trace all the way back to
the state diagram
going back to the previous
misclassification example with dips here
you can actually enter this
misclassified text into deep Seer and
deepseer will immediately produce a
state Trace that reflects the
intermediate decisions made by the iron
model after reading each word in the
input text here red means negative and
blue means positive similar to how you
step through a program The Source Code
you can step through this state trace
and look at what happens after you know
the model reads each word in the input
text and we can see that you know this
iron model actually changes minus
several times when it's reading the
input text and in particular after you
know read this word Quarters at the end
of the sentence the model suddenly
changes mind from negative to positive
right and never change it back so it
actually provides us some good hints for
further debugging further investigation
when we actually search this keyword
quarters in the training data right we
can see that the data is quite
imbalanced
there are 28 sentences mentioned these
quarters and 27 of them are labeled as
positive only one of them are labeled as
negative so that means the model
actually learns a superficial
correlation between this world quarters
and a positive opinion right so this is
very likely to be the root cause of this
misclassification
to further confirm the usefulness of
this idea we actually did a user study
with 20 28 CS students and asked them to
debug two different models train out two
different data sets using deepseer
versus another popular debugging deep
learning debugging tool called line and
we found that students using deepseer
provided more reasonable insights about
the root causes and we also fund more
error-inducing keywords in the input
sentence compared with using line
so K takeaways you know I think given
the opaqueness of deep learning I think
it's quite important for us programmers
to understand what we are building and
be responsible for the model errors and
to achieve this goal we actually need to
build new debugging tools that account
for the unique characteristics of deep
learning and to make these tools usable
to the broad population programmers we
need to transform the internals of a
deep learning model into something that
we are familiar with that are
interpretable to programmers rather than
something that only makes sense to
machine learning experts and machine
learning theorists
finally I want to give a shout out to my
collaborators at the University of
Alberta and thank you all for listening
[Applause]